hey Isaac so last time we look to
sketching out some of the ideas of this
this game I'm gonna not call it pong a
squash pong game that you can implement
with the PI game library where do we go
from here
so basically what we did in the previous
video was to basically try to understand
how the screen will look like the things
that are going to be fixed and the
objects that are gonna be moving around
and it was all about defining the
coordinates of different walls and the
paddle and the ball and everything right
and also we were thinking about okay
these two objects the ball and the
paddle they will be moving and they will
have some attributes so basically the
coordinates and where in which they are
and also with they will have some
functionality they will be able to move
and to show an update their position
right so this is what we did and this
how we define it initially right so we
know the ball will have coordinates X Y
and some class variables like the color
and the radius of that ball actually I
just realized that the color should be
something that the problem should also
have probably if you want to write so
now what we're going to be doing is to
implement that using the library called
pi game I've done my homework before
this whenever you use a library like
this you need to do your own homework
you need to go to the documentation and
read it carefully and try to find which
functions are useful for you for
whatever your purposes are as on that
I'm gonna show you quickly on the screen
the PI game website so here you have
plenty of classes definitions and
functionality so you have a class to
define the color display to draw to take
care of events to draw stuff with phones
images anything you like really so you
can do very cool games using all
functionality I'm gonna stick to
something very simple in this video
we're gonna start off by importing the
library right so if you're going to be
using this you need to install the
library in your computer right but
whenever you have done that you need to
import PI again and the very very first
thing that you need to do is to initiate
this so basically you need to call a
function code in it if you're using one
IDE like I'm doing in this video I'm
using a spider you can actually do cool
things you can just run it here and it's
just saying hello from PI game community
right so it's not doing much that's what
we do when we run this piece of code but
in this case so whenever you do program
it typically you only get that console
right and then you get output there but
now we're gonna change that we want to
be able to draw a screen right and to do
that you need to use one function from
PI game and you can look up on the
documentation for this but we're gonna
basically go at this play and we're
gonna have to set the mode and the mode
is not anything else but how big the
screen will look like so we could do
manually here just coordinates for
example 1200 600 with in hive and that
will create a screen so I'm gonna run it
something very cool about this idea is I
can just select a bit of code and run it
shift control and then you create a
blank window interesting uh actually it
is black on my operating system it
doesn't have to be black in your
operating systems why because whenever
we call this function what is happening
under the hood is that this is making
what we call a system code
so this library is talking to the
operating system and telling hey can you
please create a screen for me in which
I'm going to be doing the drawing right
but it's not the user actually doing
that directly it's the communication
with the operating system so that's why
it depends where you run the library
they behavior might change slightly
right so whenever you run this you could
store the output of that function on a
variable why I want to do that because I
know this function will return something
called a surface which is where I'm
gonna be drawing stuff so one thing is
the display and the surface is the black
part that was there and which I'm going
to be drawing things right
something I don't like from here shown
from programming point of view from the
programming point of view you will never
want to do this otherwise Torsen
and I will kill you if we see that your
hard-coding values here right so
normally you have some variables in
which you store those values and then
that makes your program way more
flexible so if you allow me what I'm
going to do is to put a comment here and
saying here are gonna be my variable and
the first thing I want to do is to draw
the main scenario right that's what I
want to do down here and for now I'm
gonna define variables with which is
1200 for now and hi this is gonna be 600
yep so now instead of using this values
here how called it you put it here with
an hi okay cool huh we thought we
haven't done much we spent like two
minutes years to get the assorted we
haven't done much and I want to to draw
something right so I want to do the
first rectangle the first wall at the
top right and for that what you need is
a function that is within the class draw
in PI again so this one is within draw
and then you need to use rectangle and
then you might be wondering well how do
I use this function well well you have
to do once again is to go on the API on
the documentation and really a quick
trick that you could do here is if you
want to you can go here to the console
and then you could write help and then
the name of the function and then you
will have what the function is expecting
so expecting something called a surface
color and then the rectangle itself
which is a different type of object so
basically initially I have to say I'm
gonna draw this on the surface that I
just created when initialize in the
display then I have to define the color
right of that one right so this is in a
different class that we call color it
understand me if I say I wanted white as
simple as that and then we actually have
to draw the rectangle which is in a tie
game dot correct and then you have to
provide two things for that one
right once again I do know how this
library works perfectly so now you need
to know what are the coordinates of the
top-left corner and then you need to
indicate the width and the height of
that rectangle so we actually did the
numbers before we're doing it once again
so the coordinate the initial coordinate
the top-left corner of that rectangle is
basically C no zero right I'm gonna put
the double zero zero for that one and
then you need to indicate in a dot in a
different taboo you need to indicate the
width and how big we want that border so
the width is gonna be the same width as
we define here because it's all the way
on the screen but then we want to draw
that for a few pixels you were saying 5
or 10 or 30 well do not guess probably
the best thing to do is to define
another variable border we say for
example 20 right and then we are going
to be using that and in case we want to
change the values we can do it at the
top of the program right so if you do
this and now we run this code and then
you look for pi again you will not see
anything and you will be all
disappointed that you will say what why
why it doesn't work well pi game is a
bit funny so you I did the drawing but I
didn't tell pi gang I did it I just
basically said I use this function yes
but you need to tell the surface that
they're having changes how you do that
well you need to call a different
function that is called flip so you need
to do PI game dot display because you
want to tell the display to refresh and
then we flip it and whenever I run this
I should be able to say it now on top as
you can see here on the video right so
it's that border good enough we want it
bigger oh we can see why to the top yeah
oh it I didn't see it first yeah okay we
can make it bigger if you want to it's
really up to you right let's leave it
like that for now I can only see one
line though is that right align across
yes so only one line so look we have to
write a full instruction just to draw
that rectangle there right so now we you
what you need to do is to draw the other
three
right but I'm not gonna be doing this in
the video I have precooked this free and
I'm gonna just copy paste with your
permission because otherwise it's gonna
take a long time and actually I was
doing something funny before I put the
color here directly when calling this
function rectangle but now I have done
that three times so what we could do is
to create a variable in which we kind of
store what is it gonna be the foreground
color and what is gonna be the
background color so here you can store
the result of calling this pygame color
wine you can put it in this variable and
now our code will be much nicer just by
using FG color in that way so there you
go if now you do this and you run this
code you will have two three walls tada
yeah perfect
yeah very good look at this now I'm
gonna try to close this window what's
happening it doesn't work it will never
work why because we haven't told the
operating system what to do we haven't
told our program what to do when the
user is clicking this cross so the first
thing you need to do is to handle this
and the only way to close this is to
using a function called Pi game dot quit
by the way this function will not work
in all operating systems easily so if
you're using a Mac you need something
else that I I will not be covering here
but if you do that yes
so that disappeared now so that's again
but if I run the whole game now it's
gonna be doing the following look boom
you're showing it and closing it that's
not good is it it's quitting itself
right so it's basically creating the
display drawing the three walls and then
saying no and have to quit but that's
not what I want what I want is to check
if the user has actually click on that
cross and then I will close the program
never before so what we need to do for
that is to create a loop an infinite
loop that will be running until the user
says otherwise so we're gonna have a
loop that is going to be true forever
until something happens
and for things happening my gang has a
different class called events and it's a
way to control what is happening how the
user is interacting with that window
right so there is a bit of detail that
I'm gonna skip here but basically you
need to call a class on the event and
pool events and whenever you've got an
event that is called quit that is
basically when the user has click on
that cross the program will stop never
earlier so basically we need to check
here a condition and check the type of
event that we've got and whenever it
that is equal to quit which is a
predefined variable within PI game
whenever that happens you break the loop
otherwise the program will continue here
and will not do anything at all just
waiting for the user to do something so
that while true means that it will carry
on doing everything above it well that's
a very good question so I'm drawing
everything right it Droste it and then
it doesn't do anything just basically
stays here just looping here doing
nothing waiting for the user to do
something or waiting for us to write
something within this while loop and
that's the way we have to somehow stop
this window from closing and it will
only close when I now click on that one
tada works right beautiful
all right so so far we have actually
just design how the game will look like
we haven't even drawn yet the ball or
the problem and that take us quite a bit
of time just to understand how the
display works how to put the walls right
and how to make the program to stay
there and wait for the user to do
something and to play or to draw the
ball so this is what we're going to do
for now just to draw the environment and
in the next video I'm gonna show you how
to create the ball how to move it around
and how to put the bubble and move it
around as well okay I put before only
two parameters but now we have two more
which is the speed that we want this to
go let's say on the horizontal axis and
the vertical one so initially for
example I'm gonna say that I just want
the ball to move
horizontally not vertically so the one